thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air
[Applause]
[Music]
he gently pulls the chair away and grabs
the doorknob
he turns he pulls
oddly there's slight resistance then he
yanks the door
and catco's life and limbs are changed
forever
a man's house is his castle it's the
place we feel
safe it's the place we raise our
children
and it's the place we keep our most
precious belongings
but to what lengths may we go to protect
our personal property in our home
when is deadly force justified
that's the question that we must answer
in the case of the shotgun booby trap
[Music]
submitted for adjudication our story
begins with a gift
the year is 1957 the place
an isolated farmhouse in mahousa county
iowa
on this day edward and bertha briony are
thrilled to learn that they're about to
inherit a fertile
eight-acre farm from bertha's parents
the shining gem amidst the
rolling golden wheat fields a farmhouse
a symbol of the american pioneer the
couple is elated
they dream of passing on their property
their children and grandchildren
little do they know this quaint little
home in the heartland is about to throw
their lives
into chaos although they love the
farmhouse ed and bertha
do not live there instead they reside in
another home outside of town they try
their best to secure the inherited
property especially to
protect the antiques and heirlooms
stored within
unfortunately the brineys grow
increasingly unable to care for the
farmhouse
and it begins to deteriorate faster than
they can repair
both time and weather batter the house
the harsh midwestern winters strip the
paint off the boards
crack the windows like broken teeth and
cave the roof in
the home becomes dilapidated and the
brinies are frustrated
the gift starts to seem less like a
blessing
and more like a curse they have no idea
how right they are worse yet the
farmhouse is isolated and vulnerable
like a haunted house
beset by troubled ghosts there are no
nearby neighbors to protect the home
and it becomes ripe for looting as the
years pass
bertha's family heirlooms start
disappearing stolen by a persistent
swarm of criminals and thieves
a series of trespassing and
house-breaking incidents inflict
more damage to the property and soon
nearly everything that bertha treasured
is gone stolen by looters that seemed to
worm their way into the house like
locusts
and like locusts strip it bare
angry and despondent the briney's post
keep
out signs and install locks but all is
in vain
for a decade ed briny listens to his
wife's pleas as she begs him to do
something meanwhile on the other side of
town
a couple of buddies are up to no good
meet one marvin katco a married gas
station attendant barely able to make
ends meet
he's been in and out of work for weeks
and is looking for some quick cash
and meet catco's soon-to-be partner in
crime marvin mcdonough
who has heard about the briny residents
and the easy money to be made there
mcdonough convinces cadco that grabbing
some antiques could earn them a pretty
penny
and catco is just desperate enough to
agree
before long the two conspirators break
in and steal some antique bottles and
jars for preserves
their little heist proves fruitful
finally something snaps in the mind of
edward briney
fed up with the looting and wanton
destruction briny cleans and oils his
20-gauge shotgun
and he climbs the flight of groaning
stairs to the second floor bedroom
a desperate plan takes shape in his mind
he ignores the uneasy feeling in the pit
of his stomach
he is a man who has had enough
fury pulsing in his veins briny enters
the north bedroom
working by the light of the late
afternoon sun he secures the shotgun to
the foot of the iron bed with wire
and runs another wire from the trigger
to the bedroom doorknob
he crouches adjusting the shotgun's aim
leveling it straight at the middle of
the door frame
where it is sure to hit the thief in the
abdomen a death sentence
and then he calls downstairs to bertha
when bertha sees ed's booby trap
she has only one qualm she doesn't want
the would-be thief to get shot in the
stomach
so bertha convinces ed to lower the gun
and to point it at the bottom of the
door instead
ed agrees and adjusts the shotgun he
nails a piece of tin over the window to
prevent anyone from seeing the trap
he loads the gun [ __ ] the trigger and
closes the door
bertha shoves a chair under the door's
knob as one last signal to thieves that
the bedroom door
isn't meant to be open at last the
brinys leave
knowing the next person to open the door
is in for a horrifying shock
meanwhile high off of their first hall
catco and mcdonough decide to go back
reasoning there must be more in the
rooms that they haven't opened yet
so the two tiptoe back onto the briny's
land under cover of darkness
but this time unbeknownst to them they
face a bloody reckoning
catko and mcdonough pry loose aboard
from a back porch window
they break and enter once inside the
house
catco goes straight to the bedrooms
while mcdonough searches downstairs
he enters the hallway no one is home but
he's careful to avoid excessive noise
the old floorboards creak with each
heavy
step catco notices a chair under the
north bedroom door
strange but no matter he gently pulls
the chair away and
grabs the doorknob he turns
he pulls oddly there's slight resistance
then he yanks the door and catko's life
and limbs are changed forever
the sound of the blast is deafening it's
chaos catco drops one of his legs a
bloody mess of tissue and bone splinters
the sickly sweet smell of gunpowder
fills the air adding to the pandemonium
catco screams in agony and mcdonough
rushes to the bedroom
he stares in dumbstruck horror catco
lies there riding
mcdonough lifts his friend on a shoulder
and half carries him down to the front
yard
from there mcdonough helps as much as he
can as catco crawls the seemingly
endless distance to the car
where the two finally rushed through the
night to the hospital
there after doctors stopped the bleeding
they explained to
catko and his wife that he needs three
to four weeks of care before the
hospital can discharge him
catco has lost a substantial amount of
bone and tissue
and his leg needs to be amputated but
almost miraculously catco barely avoids
that
horrible step yet catko's injury doesn't
prevent the law from swooping in
after a 40-day stay in the hospital
catco faces the police who arrest him on
breaking
enery and larceny charges catco pays a
fine
of 50 and serves a 60-day jail sentence
until he is paroled for good behavior
except for this catco's record is clean
but this man's ordeal is far from over
he suffers a full year in a cast and
another year in a special brace
he wrestles with pain and knows he will
walk with a limp for the rest of his
life
catco knows he was committing a crime
but the longer he sits
his leg throbbing like torture the more
he convinces himself that he doesn't
deserve
this this isn't fair
something breaks in catko's mind like
briny before him
catco decides he wants justice
catko served his time in jail and paid
his debt to society which
brought the criminal side of this case
to a close but once out of jail
catco wanted compensation for his
gruesome shotgun injuries
so like a true american cat co-filed
suit
that's right the thief sued the
homeowner catco
claimed that his leg injury resulted
from unreasonable force by the brinies
to protect their personal property by
setting up a spring gun aka a shotgun
booby trap
needless to say ed and bertha briny were
furious the case went all the way up to
the iowa supreme court
the issue whether setting up a spring
gun and uninhabited house
is considered reasonable force for
protection of property
in other words was edward allowed to set
up a shotgun booby trap to protect his
house and home
remember the house was unoccupied at the
time of the break-in
so how far does the right to
self-defense actually
go we take you to the courthouse where
the argument between the lawyers for
each side
is about to begin
good morning this court has had an
opportunity to review the record
the party's briefs our council is ready
to begin oral argument
uh yes your honor bruce palmer
representing appellants mr and mrs briny
yes justice jerry hesslinger for mr
catgo appley
all right then let's proceed mr palmer
what do you have to say thank you and
may it please the court
it is frankly a miscarriage of justice
that an admitted thief would
seek monetary damages from the
homeowners he tried to burgle
my clients edward and bertha briny did
everything right
they followed the law in setting up a
mere deterrent in their unoccupied home
a home which was clearly not meant for
guests especially trespassing intruders
with
intent to burglarize the home for 10
years the brineys repeatedly installed
locks
posted many no trespassing signs boarded
up windows
and even desperately sought assistance
from the sheriff's department
but none of these efforts prevented
continuous break-ins and thefts
to the family's heirloom home catgo the
thief
had no right to even set foot on the
briny's land
your honor the key to deciding this case
is the oldest legal question on the
books
does the punishment fit the crime the
obvious answer here is
no the constitution itself prohibits
cruel and unusual punishment in criminal
cases
but it also makes sense in a civil case
like this one
my client admitted he was guilty of
breaking and entering and larceny
in the night time but he was arrested he
served his time and he paid the required
fine
he paid his debt to society and the
brines
yes the brineys had a right to protect
their property but to the extent of
ruining a decent man's life by blowing
off one of his legs
all the brownies intended with the
spring gun in the bedroom was to
scare intruders they had no desire or
intention to
seriously maim or kill anyone catgo
while he tries to play the oops i made a
little mistake
card actually carefully planned the
burglary to steal the briny's valuables
and sell them for his own benefit
he's a convict a repeat offender and had
no right to expect warmth or safety in a
vacant home which he knew had been
repeatedly vandalized
imagine if he seriously cut himself
while breaking one of the farmhouse
windows
that could be just as dangerous as a
shotgun but we would
all agree that the brineys would not be
liable for his injuries then
this situation is exactly the same
catgo's injuries resulted from his own
bad
decisions oh that's going too far my
client not only suffered the horrendous
injury at the time the shotgun
blew off much of his bone and leg tissue
but almost had his leg amputated
needed crutches and a special brace for
almost two years
and still suffers substantial pain to
this very day
all because he attempted to take a few
antique bottles to sell
so he could keep himself and his wife
above water i
appreciate your arguments counselors but
the law is clear
the relevant question for the court is
whether the actions of the brines was
reasonable
akatko did not have permission to enter
the premises and did not have permission
to steal the briny's belongings
that much is clear however as a society
we don't want people setting up shotgun
booby traps or
planting landmines in their yards your
honor
any reasonable person knows the terrible
damage a shotgun can do at point-blank
range
indeed the fact that the brineys lowered
the aim of the gun is an admission of
that fact
thus they obviously intended to
grievously harm the next person to open
that door
in this case it was poor mr catgo mr
palmer
do you think the briny's trap was
reasonable
i do your honor was it reasonable for
them to be upset and want to prevent
further break-ins
yes did they try less drastic measures
to accomplish their goal prior to the
spring gun
yes did those measures stop the stealing
and vandalism
no does it make sense for them to have
taken a more extreme measure
yes your honor you called it a trap but
that implies that it was
out in the wild and that anyone walking
in public could have come within the
sights of the shotgun but
the brineys were careful to only protect
their own home and place their deterrent
in their own bedroom your honor the flaw
in the brownies argument is clear
what if it had been someone else that
opened the door that night what if some
young boys
out for a walk had decided to explore
the dark home as an adventure
as children sometimes do what if the
boys having no plan to steal or
vandalize had wandered through the home
and then in one
awful blast a child's life had been lost
clearly the death of an innocent young
child would not be reasonable just to
protect some property
what else can we conclude the hidden gun
trap was
intended to catch someone by surprise
and cause a devastating personal injury
or worse
imagine a person on trial for attempted
murder and claiming that it couldn't be
murder because he only aimed for
someone's non-vital organs
preposterous if my client had not been
accompanied by his friend
he would have bled to death the brownies
were out for blood and they
got it now it's on their hands my client
simply wants compensation for the damage
that they did to him
are we to suggest that a homeowner can
never use deadly force to protect his
home
is that the precedent you want to set mr
palmer
under what circumstances if any is a
spring gun
a legally permitted device for
protection of personal property
your honor the law is settled that
property owners may use substantial
force
even spring guns and shotguns to protect
their property
under certain circumstances including a
home invasion
especially at night who's to say the
briny family was
not protecting a dwelling where mrs
briney may be spending time on her own
she has a right to protect her own life
with deadly force
so the only unreasonable matter here is
cat goes asking this
court to award him money for an injury
he sustained by
illegally entering a home where the
homeowner might have been dwelling at
the time
your honor opposing counsel conveniently
omits that part of the well-settled law
that says spring guns or other
mechanical devices installed to cause
serious bodily harm or death
may only be used if the homeowner is
present in the dwelling
while the trap is set we may not like
the reason mr catko was there
but his status as a trespasser shouldn't
justify homeowners throughout the
country
rigging firearms to shoot anyone at any
time
thank you i think i've heard enough any
closing remarks mr palmer
thank you well it was mere property my
clients were protecting
these were belongings in a home where
mrs briney
frequently spent time thus this case
should be
looked upon as one in which the law
permits use of a spring gun
it might be different if the belongings
were in a shack or a barn but
they were not it was merely luck that
the brineys were not present at the time
of the home invasion
yet mr catko seeks to punish the brineys
for the
good fortune that they were not home at
the time he broke in
notwithstanding council's seemingly
sound argument it is completely
unsupported by actual
iowa law any reasonable person would
have realized that a 20-gauge shotgun
precariously wired to fire into a
doorway any part of a doorway
could cause serious bodily harm or death
to an entrant
thus the spring gun set up by the
brineys was legally impermissible
thank you councillors this matter is
adjourned
i will return soon with the court's
decision
justice moore wrote the decision of the
iowa supreme court in february of 1971
and the president that it set is still
the law of the land in iowa and many
states today
pause this video and let me know in the
comments how you think this case came
out
the iowa supreme court held that the
rule of law to be applied was this
one may in fact use reasonable force to
protect mere property
but a homeowner may not use a means of
force that will take human life
or inflict great bodily harm the fact
that a trespasser may be acting in
violation of
law doesn't change that rule and the
only time the setting of a spring gun is
justified
is if a trespasser is committing a
felony of violence
or one punishable by death or where a
trespasser is endangering human life
by his act in other words the brinys
the homeowners were in the wrong
it was unlawful to set up their spring
gun booby trap
and what happened to the brinys well
hold on to your hats
the jury's verdict for catco and against
the brineys awarded catco
twenty thousand dollars for actual
damages plus another ten thousand
dollars in punitive damages
the jury found that the briny's booby
trap was so
heinous that the couple should not only
pay for the actual damages
but also ten thousand dollars just to
punish them
so is it fair or unfair that a
trespasser attempting to burglarize your
house has any protections at all
it's difficult to disagree that human
life is more important than property
no matter how sentimental the items but
what do you think
the case of the shotgun booby trap is
the first in a new series on this
channel
i hope you liked it because it took
about 10 times longer than my normal
videos
this is a huge experiment because
publishing on youtube is risky and
in fact this video probably got
demonetized
which is why my creator friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or
the dreaded algorithm it's called nebula
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream
nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house our content ad-free
and also experiment with new original
series that probably wouldn't work on
youtube
in fact if you like this episode of the
case of the shotgun booby trap
you can find an extended version on
nebula that i can't show on youtube and
when i say nebula is built by creators
for creators i really mean it
nebula features lots of youtube's top
educational-ish creators like
real engineering half as interesting
tier zoo knowing better real-life lore
and tons of others and we get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on youtube for example the nebula
exclusive series called working titles
where every episode
a different creator breaks down their
favorite tv intro sequence
polyphonic did the game of thrones intro
patrick willems did the x-men animated
series
and i'll be covering law and order very
very soon
[Music]
seriously we worked really hard on this
and we're all really proud of the result
the project is self-funded
we're not backed by investors and we've
managed to make this ad free and with no
dreaded algorithm so what does this have
to do with curiosity stream
well they love educational content and
educational creators so they were the
perfect partner for nebula
we just recently worked out a deal where
if you sign up for curiosity stream with
a link in the description
not only will you get one free month of
curiosity stream
but you'll also get a nebula
subscription for free and to be clear
that nebula subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member
which means that for less than twenty
dollars a year not only do you get
unlimited access to curiosity streams
massive library of gorgeous
high budget documentaries but you'll
also get to enjoy the private playground
for
youtube's best educational creators at
no additional charge for as long as
you're a curiosity stream member and
you'll be supporting creators like me
directly so you can go to the link in
the description or you can go to
curiositystream.com
legal eagle and if you sign up using the
link below not only will you be able to
access curiosity streams amazing
documentaries like
101 events that made the 20th century
which includes my favorite episode on
watergate for reasons that are probably
obvious
but you'll also get a subscription to
nebula for free for as long as you
remember
seriously it's less than 20 bucks just
click on the link
so what do you think did the court get
it right or was this a travesty of
justice
leave your objections in the comments
and until next time
i'll see you in court